to primarily only eating meat
eating meat only eating meat what have
you found and what to what can you share
with other folks that might be helpful
for them to like at least
explore eliminating some other types of
foods from their diet i would suggest
people try at least to eliminate grains
and dairy i know a lot of people in the
carnivore area uh eat a lot of dairy but
i think if you're not having success
with carnivore diet or if you have some
sort of inflammatory disorder or mood
disorder dairy can be
a problem for a lot of people i think
part of the reason women are less
inclined to eat meat is because they
think meat will make them fat what does
make people fat dairy is a really easy
way to gain weight grains massively
especially the gluten containing grains
and then processed foods and then
obviously if you're overeating calories
about some people that might say that's
not true grains and dairy don't make you
fat i mean there's like those are fat
people
[Laughter]
probably so